c'est une réalité qui touche de plus en
plus de français avec l'âge et les
difficultés corporelle qui s'accumulent
il devient très difficile de réaliser
les gestes les plus simples
voilà une facilité d'ouverture de porte
simplement avec l'aide d'une carte
voilà ce qui est très pratique pour des
personnes à mobilité réduite
ouvrir une porte c'est voler ou encore
déplacer des objets le quotidien peu
tourné à l'enfer lorsque la perte
d'autonomie s'accélère heureusement
aujourd'hui une série de technologies et
d'outils existent pour soulager les
concernés l'idée c'est de montrer qu'on
peut aussi rester à domicile malgré
parfois de très gros handicap de des
maladies comme alzheimer avec pas
forcément du père friess personnel 24
heures sur 24
mais grâce à des outils qui du coup vont
vous permettre ce maintien domicile
réunis au domaine du mes rentes et pour
ses portes ouvertes les professionnels
de santé de l'habitat de saint quentin
en yvelines ont pu ainsi présenter leurs
solutions pour continuer à vivre chez
soi personnes qui occupent un système
anti dérapante s'est vite principalement
visés par l'opération les personnes
âgées bien sûr mais les aidant aussi la
personne a des grosses difficultés à se
relever ou même s'asseoir
ça peut être intéressant si on peut voir
des références donc là le monsieur m'a
donné ça à sa carte parce que
effectivement si je vais à la formation
m'a jamais proposé sa pharmacie et dans
les yvelines plus de cette portion de la
population a 75 ans ou plus
un chiffre inférieur à la moyenne
nationale de 9 %
l insee prévoit un doublement de ces
données pour 2050